I'm just gonna be a passenger on this
lovely ride Oh everybody my name is
markiplier I'm here with my boys say hi
my boys here they are that's my boys
anyway that's all I got
Thank You bobbleheads my skirt here and
welcome to pacify with market ways say
hi mark away
well you talk during my intro so I'm
gonna do it six more times so what's
this game
this is pacified way do you oh sure
[Applause]
welcome back to pacify this time with
mark and Bob they've not played the game
so I'm going to sit back and let them
take the steering wheel oh no which one
of yous who wants to make a deal what
the hell's that thing about the game
show the briefcases lets me know Howie
Mandel who's Howie Mandel I'm looking at
you how we I um how that's mark it's me
uh you look like god what's that
actresses name
who's Bob look like Rosie O'Donnell I
don't know all right I look like that
actress yeah that actress yeah just call
me that actress you're a brunette you're
very you're very lovely brown haired
actress that's me
wait you're Chet Bronstein I don't know
you look like a generic man Chet
Bronstein
hey did you mean chef Bernstein Oh chef
Bernstein you look just like the Burning
Man well I've got something to cook up
for you today welcome to Wayne's house
okay get out of the way I'm just gonna
go in all right why are we pan ink pie
in pair work Tiffany or requires a key
is there a key to this box no hmm Oh
says Wade guess we go out look around
and either find a key or hey I thought a
cellar hey hey come around the left side
of the house is a cellar I'm waiting on
the other side hang on I'm finding my
own stuff I thought I'm going in wow
what a good fine found the cellar that's
what I said I guess I'm the leader here
come down to the mayor
I found a seller to sell her oh hey guys
I found this okay I like the look of
this place oh what's that squeak what is
that the opening closing of doors I
think who's opening and closing the door
I thought you know I haven't touched a
single doorman Oh guys I got wood wood
yeah I got wood I got wood I got wood
wait where are you guys cuz I go hey
baby
how's it going did you find it baby yeah
come look where where are you gar you
we're just wandered around the basement
I'm in the basement yeah I wasn't right
now I gotta find you Bob I'm back I'm in
the wine room I guess oh wait that's you
wait where's the baby oh wait no Bob
found the baby whoa baby what the hell
oh hey yeah this is the baby I found oh
my god okay took you to pick it up I
took the baby
no don't carry it around mom I'll carry
the baby respectful baby like a football
can you see it am i carrying it to you
guys yeah yeah it's like in your right
it's in your hand
your left hand you're carrying it around
good good good good oh you know what
guys I think I figured out the point of
this game what in the room where the
baby was there's all these wine racks uh
are you sure we're supposed to go find
all the bottles and put them back in the
wine racks
do you hear this well now I hear my yeah
I heard like are you upstairs Bob no
cool stories wait don't mess with us we
know you've played this game you don't
hear though you guys didn't hear that
what that [ __ ] hear that what is it
it sounds like footsteps up here it's
out spurt Clem you're leading me into a
trap I know this I know you how do we go
home baby hi baby
this oh why is that what is that
wait what is that oh I'm just a pair of
this train
oh god oh god oh god okay Bobby got a
bomb alright yeah it's coming this way
um I kind of want to see it well you
just wait a second always know where to
go is it not Bob come up here okay that
seems safe I don't know where it went
there's a baby baby you want that baby
you know carry a book Oh God okay what
are you what are you you stay in front
you stay in front okay all right I'm
saying for I got a baby baby don't like
that walk cycle yeah that's not it
that's not a good walk so I'm gonna try
to speak with her okay listen
at wait what stopped me hey listen look
my friends trying to have a conversation
it's rude of you to be here listen you
come here you I want to talk with you
but what
[Applause]
I don't know I just tried talking with
her Oh God Oh God
key I found a hole key okay all right
there's a lot of doors labeled Hall
so you use that for all the hall doors
okay I've got a babby what if I just
closed you out there is that is that
good for us Oh what was that laughing
that's not what you want to hear
laughing is usually never good she may
turn on you in an instant that's how she
killed my wife Gretchen giving her the
doll has always worked I have to keep
telling myself it isn't her anymore okay
meets daughter to evil my daughter has
been possessed by darkness that cannot
be controlled if she's still here you're
in danger I can only think of one way
you may stop her for good burn the
marked dolls burn oh I have matches I
have matches how do I match matches I've
got matches I've been locking myself a
different arts of the house trying to
think of a way to save her I have a set
of five keys did you guys read this one
no we did ours in different areas of the
house there's a great hall bedrooms
basement attic and main doors I'll let
the single Keane each area to unlock
another Oh sheets thumping around is she
really
when you really think about it is she oh
like that growling what is that I don't
sound growling I don't hear the growling
right now are there
okay well I'm in the prime in the like
the library and there's some serious
growling happening I'm mo I have a key
guys I have a bedroom key oh good good
start unlocking the bedrooms I'm in the
Attic
let's get out there with you no I don't
see her I haven't seen her in a bit whew
all I hear is growling really close to
me and I have no idea what got a hall
key and a bedroom key needed on the main
staircase who's on the staircase here
height weight is on either side there's
a bedroom right here there's a bedroom
on the outside too after Oh knees not
Jesus Christ that's loud what the [ __ ]
was that ah I don't know but that was
really loud wait you're being quiet you
need to answer our questions I don't
know Bob - Bob - the bedroom key I don't
know is she angry by one of you not by
me we have a bedroom door right there
feel like you're just straight-up
leading us into all the jump-scare traps
mark we're out here I found nothing so
this is the same bedroom okay I hear the
growl yeah okay the growling is is
louder oh she's going up the stairs I
see her oh crap she's coming towards us
I don't see her
why I see her I saw her through a window
I I can't see her from here
look I don't know I've read a note that
said you got to burn things in the
boiler well that would be oh [ __ ] hi
okay well fine my wife and I ran the
only funeral parlor in town I don't read
notes man why are you reading no never
afraid of the dead in fact we were both
very interested in it handling and
preparing dead bodies was a part of our
daily life dude readings for nerds stop
reading you nerd I just okay there I
don't want to be in here this is a dead
end
anyway so we should be finding the attic
or basement keys in one of the bedrooms
right but I was in the base in the attic
attic there's a babby in here is that
good
oh is that the main staircase don't
close it on me mark I need hall in
bedroom mark where I don't have bedroom
key that's BA I've I'm here I'm here
oh Jesus did she open doors I think so
she was not very far both
right here in this corner there's two
one of the left as well flawed as a
bathroom
oh is that opening and closing doors
constantly yeah please thank you
oh wait this just leads there that's the
same you idiot when we're all here and
the doors are opening and closing that
does not make me glad that someone had
the key that would have sucked
yeah you know how it is I'm always on
your side man all right so we've been we
found the attic key
what do you mean add a key I went in the
Attic is it in the Attic
there's a door in the Attic we have to
have it had it key for no then no we
haven't found the attic key okay should
be in one of the rooms Oh found it
attic key got it all right well now when
you pick it up to the Attic
who's got the bedroom key is this you
mark me no that's my stairs I have the
whole key okay I remember that Bob it's
just good to have all these doors
unlocked in case we have to run bedroom
key right there
thank you the Attic I think is over this
way maybe it's not I'll never tell what
is the width oh the wood is for the
boiler we burn the thing in the boiler I
got it here babies are released
the key is their parade of babies also
why is there a parade of baby yeah why I
said that's that's my question but I
already got one yeah I have one too
she's coming up we gotta go another way
oh [ __ ] there's no other way what do you
mean we got to go the other way there's
another way okay loops around those so I
know yeah okay okay how do we burn them
waking basement door wait I just saw a
baby run by here yeah there's one in
this corner is that good is this one
supposed to be like this where where are
you I was also in the basement how does
he remember how to get to the basement
do the babies like a tractor or
something what's the deal with the
babies hi hi boiler room is unlocked how
do we get to the basement you idiot
the star you see this oh my god I hate
you okay I found it what wait where he's
in the basement I think wait scream that
a moment ago yeah I think Susan Bob
she's down there yeah she's down there
oh yeah she's down here alright i i
lured her away check out mark it's just
like yes he's down here she's down it
goes down here wait where'd you go wait
I saw you run in here there you are
I'm just trying to find all the doors to
unlock before I die you're scared of a
like a little girl is that what you're
scared of
oh girl floating right by the basement
right here okay so yes shall we do this
sir I shoved this nut and yes a baby air
burnt it okay that's that's horrible
what she didn't like that hmm
where's he going he's going all right I
won't a beater a beater
oh wait honky honky mark come back no
I'm gonna get a baby here come here you
guys [ __ ] she's not happy about this I
burned another it's not a mark doll you
need the doll that's gray with the marks
on it hey guys she's pacified all right
I handed her a good doll and now she's
cold okay all right cool oh cool hey hey
you I seem better your face is still
weird all right well I'm gonna get
around around my burner doll do you have
the right doll I'm not an idiot nobody
explained it to me I don't know how I
was supposed to know that myself that
was she bad oh she's mad she's mad isn't
she she's mad she's real mad okay that
was really loud listen guys yeah duh
unbelievably loud screaming from down
there yeah Oh
found another one alright bringing it
down what the [ __ ] why is this as good
as exist
are you mad at me
can I be not said am i is it possible
that not sigh I am a tall you what I I
am a doll you're
come back to the boiler room come back
to the boiler room now that doesn't
sound good it's a good thing for you
it's the only way to get you back to
size but there's another there's a
marked all right here arning oh you
can't blame me for playing the game here
hi oh hey freakin Jesus Bob go to the
boiler room touch the fire I don't touch
the oh I back to normal yeah okay we
also drop your keys wherever she got you
Yeah right keys again I don't have any
more wood at the moment so if you guys
see what I got and I got it you big baby
here we go burning up I'm the only one
who's winning this all y'all stupid
forest
y'all stupid fools ye all to be all
stupid for I burned like four dollars
you guys are burn none yeah I got one
I'm going to the boiler let's do this
[ __ ] Oh do this
I got wood too I'm just killing it I am
destroying it
[Music]
I'm accustomed to she's not happy she
know she's supremely unhappy really
worried please stop smooching doors
please god no
I hope no one is in the base she was
really coming after me holy boy no
there's more wood in the attic if you
guys need it I'm looking for the fire
for me alright hello I was a baby
your own body
[Music]
yes I'm dying man look I'm at B pro
level but I'm not gonna let you drag
down my ranking here come here you you
scamp
I gotcha all right I'm going to burn
this baby are you just supposed to find
the mark dolls by their little tip eat a
piece is that it some are running some
are standing still so yeah whatever
she's up that way thank you
I got a regular doll the pacifier okay
cool cuz I'm smart big brain there's
only one left I think there's only one
doll left how do you use the regular
doll you just push one and hand it to
her and I think you just like Marie
Presley is she's like approaching where
you at you scary lady
come on pacify you so goood
whoa got her got her got her okay i
pacify her [ __ ] she really does just
kind of like out of nowhere just like
where's the last marked copies in like
the courtyard maybe
can she be outside that a thing it
sounded like she was outside da where
was that it's not like where we start
dude why are you so bad at this game
yeah wait why don't you know what's
happening I turned the corner she was
there man's bammy harder
dude just build I hear tippy-tap he's in
the Attic last baby Oh found it found it
I got the last baby okay she's coming to
me wait I'm doing it I'm going for it
here we go alright wait don't burn it
right away I need to I need to turn
again right away burning it right away
alright you have three seconds yes she's
literally like Bert Bert Bert oh there's
one more oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] sound good what
happened is there still one lucky
there's only one left
she's pacified okay well seem as calm as
she had saved before
oh no the opposite actually she got me
through the door I'm gonna pass whoa
whoa is she glowing red I think she's
blowing red isn't she whoa okay all
right goodbye mark yeah what's up go
what's up my bro I'm gonna follow her
around all right oh my god she's so fast
she flies in like a thousand miles an
hour okay I am out of regular dolls so
whoa why is she so fast
I'm normal oh my god she's so fast she's
literally so fast Wade can you get off
your lazy behind and help us I'm looking
for the dolls
oh Christ in some stupid corner mark
where you just I'm just gonna check the
basement again I lit a fire if you want
to go touch the fire it's so loud yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's loud we all know
it's like
she's in the library
yeah pacifying doesn't seem to work very
long for like two seconds and that is
like she got me she got me good get that
good go become a human
I will I've dropped all the keys in the
basement
I checked the basement a lot so I don't
know about that oh the boil is not on
fire I got you I'm coming I'm coming I
guess you're careful oh oh don't come
down here [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's uh hi
I'm a doll now
yeah wait can you waves no wood can you
wait you wait you have done nothing
there's wood in the base thing yeah
there's wood in the basement I'm looking
for it oh my god
wait I've burned like five Dolph oh
she's coming she's coming she's coming
be ready to pacify be ready the only one
who could do anything about this we
gotta find it last baby doll okay I did
not find it yeah oh geez I thought its
stairs by the library I don't think that
it's in the basement it can move they
are running around some of them are
standing still I'm not hearing any
tippy-tap ease I was but I am no longer
hearing maybe tippy Chappy's so it's
probably some really hard to find plays
yes someplace that I haven't seen or
something like that oh go away she's in
like the middle of the second story like
near the near the like main staircase
adult mark there's a good doll here okay
coming coming coming coming right here
in the floor
alright this would be like the last one
she's in that courtyard where is that's
oh there she is oh she's coming she's
coming
I got her okay I'm gonna go up to the
second floor and look around their wall
fees for I just did a full loop of the
Attic unless there's somewhere that's
like hard to get you in the Attic I
don't think it's up here yeah I don't
think so it has to be I'm like I said go
what she was just I turned around and
she was on me holding a baby doll ooh
like she took it from me I didn't even
hand it to her she just grabbed it oh
she's on the second floor she's coming
oh god yeah
dan go make sure I'm gonna go make sure
the boilers lit don't even worry about
I'm gonna scout around as a little baby
maybe I'll be able to find it [ __ ] me I
don't want it all to be on me I'm
terrible at this
all right I'm coming downstairs just so
I could turn human again just in case
not on fire coming down
is she down there no she's on the first
floor near the entrance to the basement
eat eat Yates all right son fire okay
cool thank you
we're gonna run out wood here we still
got piles around just like the base we
got one more here I've got the last doll
you've got it okay good it's lit its lit
its lit its lit fam she's in the kitchen
she's in the kitchen all right get down
here be able to go stroller my bro how
do we do it Oh oh cool so we're totally
safe hey cool all right
oh she's dead
oh I got her body what the hell oh all
right this is weird this feels really
weird this feels really weird she's
always like keep the body over burn her
or we can take her with us what why
would we burn her yeah she dead or she
just not creepy saying those are the two
options why would we burn her little
girl I kind of want a burner why would
we burn her she's scary don't point at
me
she didn't even hurt us she just turned
us small I mean that is true that is a
pretty harmless like crazy supernatural
thing to do if murder we would just burn
her body are you crazy
maybe it's the better maybe we're
releasing her soul from all the
suffering maybe since she's a little
girl not that little a raging demon that
should be burning
she's like 17 years old she's had a
pretty good life you just making that
assumption this is very clearly a little
girl and you two were murderous [ __ ]
she's like as tall as we are I mean very
clearly a little girl
baby dolls it's clearly a little girl I
like baby dolls look that's not your
business but doesn't mean I'm the one
who's carrying her and I say we just let
her live and take her with us but Bob
and I outnumber you and say Bern are you
gonna take you gonna take her from me I
would if I could yeah I would if I could
you can't see listen okay give me one
good reason why we should burn this poor
little girl who's probably been through
hell because she might connect a demon
and clearly still possessed that she's
staying on your shoulder even though
you're not holding her or some I am very
strong levitating on your shoulder
mistake for mine to be in capacity is
rugs every day it's days on edge you are
it's a matter of physics like 38% why of
the width of her body is on you and
she's balancing on it that's clearly
either her doing it on purpose or
supernatural levitation just because you
don't do shrugs everyday doesn't mean
that you can understand what the
capability is in my shoulder it's
physics it's physical strength how
cheers that we should wrap body what
she's been walking around this dirty
house and floor for how many days hours
whatever and her feet are exquisitely
clean only a demon would not get dirty
feet not denying that she is probably
possessed and she yes she was floating
off the ground but all systems cost
money burning the body saves us it
listen it's a long term sale all
ridiculous
lovely work we're over complicating this
who hired us for this job the dad what
did the dad say we had to do burn the
dolls
yeah the dolls did he pay us to raise
his daughter for the rest of our lives I
was gonna raise the daughter did he pay
us to carry a human body out of his
house and load it in our van no why are
you doing work we're not getting paid
for put it in the boiler let's go I do
not agree with this it feels morally
reprehensible well I guess you couldn't
not get
for the work on your own I ain't helping
all right Wade you've seen cases like
this before what do you usually do call
for help what I'm calling for help right
now
r5 screw yes I'm gonna walk out this
front door and you know watch from a
safe distance yeah whatever whatever man
putting her in this which is good enough
description that snot good marks what
are you doing with this person oh let's
get out here why
what look mark I need you give us such a
creepy work man
oh crap oh she says spooky
[Music]
she can't so you would have worded the
right what you tried to make me not do
the right thing very badly absolute
animal you consigned that poor girl to a
life of paranormal haunting and
scientific testing is that not a better
option is though a different ending hey
you made it you made a strong statement
there
thanks man meaningless but strong I
think I made the right call there it's
just a poor little girl even if she's a
demon girl she is what she is and who
are we to intrude on her right for
existence
you're like the geared like a year you
you when you that's your bad you suck
good ending I was just trying to
convince you get the bad ending good
thing I didn't listen to you you
murderous psychopath good job me and
Mark yeah Bob and I we're on the same
page it's always and forever best
outcome possible we know suck it Wade
[Music]